oggi vi offro una visione economica e
sociale per l'economia green riflessione
per il post covip ambiente di vita più
pulito sviluppo sostenibile solidarietà
sociale sono i tre pilastri fondamentali
sui quali costruire una visione per il
futuro dobbiamo per affrontare il
cambiamento climatico dobbiamo subito
dire che quando c'è un'emergenza ci
vogliono due visioni complementari una
immediata e una di lungo periodo
possiamo dire con la metafora quando la
casa brucia e importante avere i
pompieri che spengono l'incendio e non
ci importa se i loro stivali calpestano
i tappeti
ma quando l'incendio è finito occorre
portare gli architetti gli ingegneri per
ricostruire il nostro ambiente
prendiamo spunto da due errori già fatti
in questa fase di emergenza
il primo errore che non abbiamo stampato
moneta io ricordo che nelle fasi di
emergenza
la moneta come hanno fatto gli stati
uniti d'america quindi c'è un esempio
concreto nel mondo la moneta raggiunge
tutti il cosiddetto concetto di
helicopter mani ovvero quel denaro che
viene sparso in tutta l'economia
raggiunge i lavoratori dipendenti i
bambini i pensionati i nonni le scuole
gli imprenditori quelli che muovono
l'economia i lavoratori dipendenti le
casalinghe in questo senso si sa che al
posto di lavoro garantito sia chi non lo
sa
ottiene un beneficio invece noi in
europa al contrario degli americani che
in questo si sono dimostrati
paradossalmente comunque diciamo più
come dire lungimiranti o più solidari
solidali con la popolazione di come
abbiamo fatto noi in europa abbiamo
parlato di debito
ora il debito a un problema perché
perché il debito deve essere
e quanto dura le tasse che dobbiamo
aumentare per ripagare il debito
pubblico
bene se il debito da tre anni saranno i
lavoratori dei prossimi tre anni che
devono sopportare l'onere del debito
se il debito è a 99 anni ci saranno più
generazioni sui quali spalmare
quest'onere quindi questo è un problema
che ancora non abbiamo risolto
il secondo errore che non abbiamo avuto
visioni in grande ma abbiamo previsto
misure tampone
ora voglio offrirvi un esempio storico
nel 1918 quando al governo c'era
vittorio emanuele orlando e in banca
d'italia c'era bonaldo stringher la
industria della seta italiana che era
una delle principali industrie
esportatrici del nostro paese ebbe una
grave crisi perché perché nell'estate
del 1918 il franco svizzero si svalutò
ovvero la lira si rivaluta moltissimo
sul franco svizzero fino ad arrivare a
scusate a 230 lire in queste condizioni
tutti i costi che l'industria serica
aveva sostenuto prima di questa
rivalutazione avevano messo fuori
mercato
la loro produzione una crisi sistemica
di un intero settore fondamentale per la
nostra economia
cosa fece la banca d'italia istituire un
ufficio di lego ufficio centrale per il
mercato serico istituito con il favore
del consiglio dei ministri del 29
settembre del 1918 con decreto
luogotenenziale 1417 cosa fece questo
ufficio nel dicembre 1918 fino alla
primavera del 1919 vendette con la lira
ormai di nuovo ritornata ai livelli
normale tutta la produzione che aveva
acquistato quindi conti economici aveva
acquistato per 382 milioni di lire
i 2,5 milioni di kg di tutta la
produzione della seta e li rivende te a
430 quindi con un bel guadagno per il
settore pubblico italiano
in questo senso pensare in grande
ha poi ottenuto dei benefici veniamo ad
oggi
oggi la nostra industria della moda è
sostanzialmente al tracollo
perché tutta la stagione che è stata
invenduta per via del look da un la
primavera è andata persa come pensiamo
di
sostenere questo grave problema
beh io direi pensando in grande come
bonaldo stringher fece nel 1918 diciamo
in maniera chiaramente così ipotetica lo
stato italiano si compra tutto lo stock
della merce invenduta in tutti i negozi
le bancarelle d'italia quindi sgorga
completamente il canale distributivo e
poi lo regala ai bambini poveri del
terzo mondo
quello che doveva servire per vestire 60
milioni italiani sicuramente troverà
posto per dare vestiti a tanti miliardi
di poveri nel mondo
che cosa ci guadagna l'italia
reputazione innanzitutto e soprattutto
aver sostenuto con un acquisto che alla
fine porta come ho detto il beneficio
della reputazione un'intera industria
invece che metterà in ginocchio con
scorte di invenduto design che non
partono scuole di design che ritardano
giovani che non trovano lavoro e un
ritardo che si accumula questi sono
diciamo delle idee
guardiamo adesso al futuro il futuro ha
bisogno come abbiamo detto di lotta ai
cambiamenti climatici è l'argomento di
oggi noi abbiamo concordato vi ricordo a
livello delle nazioni unite tre grandi
direttrici rispetto dell'accordo di
parigi
cioè mantenere l'aumento della
temperatura sotto i due gradi centigradi
garantire l'accesso universale ai
servizi energetici a tutti i cittadini
del mondo
ricordo che ci sono un miliardo e
trecento quasi milioni di persone che
non hanno accesso all'elettricità in
questo momento nel mondo ridurre le
morti premature dovute all'inquinamento
lo scenario delle grandi
organizzazioni mondiali a cominciare
dalle nazioni unite e dalla yeah cioè la
organizzazione internazionale per
l'energia prevede un aumento di domanda
di energia fino a 27 per cento in più
quindi maggiore inquinamento e quindi
necessità di nuove tecnologie per
combattere le emissioni che causa del
cambiamento climatico
ora le politiche che possiamo mettere in
campo per questo ricordo richiedono il
coordinamento internazionale nazionale
locale su due filoni mitigazione e
adattamento che cosa sono queste parole
la mitigazione è il modo in cui noi
affrontiamo le cause dei cambiamenti
climatici
per esempio riducendo le emissioni di
gas serra
l'adattamento è quel modo di agire che
significa affrontare gli effetti
negativi di qualcosa che non possiamo
cambiare per esempio quindi sviluppando
colture agricole più resilienti al
calore alle bombe d'acqua alla grandine
in maniera tale da continuare a poter
sfamare la popolazione invece che avere
carestie la mitigazione a beneficio
globale l'adattamento funziona a livello
locale la mitigazione ha effetti nel
lungo termine
l'adattamento comporta soluzione di
breve termine come vedete breve lungo
termine globale locale sono già due
dimensioni fondamentali che devono
essere affrontate con
contesti sociali e politici appropriati
perché perché i costi della mitigazione
sono globali e quindi devono come dire
ricadere sull'intera collettività
internazionale i costi di adattamento
locali invece devono essere calati nelle
specifiche realtà locali
tutto questo dopo questa chiacchierata
vi fa subito saltare agli occhi una
parola
beh ma c'è grande incertezza che ne
facciamo di tutte queste belle parole se
non sappiamo esattamente come andranno
le cose ora dal punto di vista economico
incertezza vuol dire mancanza di
sicurezza degli approvvigionamenti di
acqua di energia di cibo per l'intera
popolazione e i costi per sostenere
questa incertezza potrebbero essere
proibitivi ora faccio sempre appello a
episodi del passato negli anni novanta
per fronteggiare le catastrofi degli
uragani in particolare per il ragazzo
andrew fu disegnato al sistema
finanziario
un nuovo strumento chiamato cat e bones
catastrofi bonds che cos'era non era
nient'altro che una variante della
solita obbligazioni finanziarie che
conosciamo nel mercato comperò collegato
un meccanismo particolare per garantire
dalla catastrofe
il sistema economico in che modo allora
se io sono la compagnia di assicurazione
e devo ripagare un evento catastrofico
non riesco a raccogliere un premio
abbastanza per poterlo sostenere
e quindi o non lo ripago o vado in
fallimento i catastrofi bot
lo spiego in maniera che gli studenti di
economia mi perdoneranno per la banalità
con quello di co
praticamente sono delle obbligazioni che
se tutto va bene funzionano come prima
cioè continuano a pagare una cedola è
essere ripagato il capitale a fine
periodo
se però si verifica l'evento
catastrofico che cosa succede
l'investitore perde il suo capitale che
rimane quindi
anni della compagnia di assicurazioni
che a questo punto può ripagare i danni
che cosa abbiamo fatto abbiamo condiviso
il rischio fra la compagnia di
assicurazione e l'investitore ora per un
problema mondiale pubblico è
fondamentale come quello della
mitigazione e dell'adattamento che ha
costi incerti
io vi propongo uno strumento analogo che
ho chiamato transitional bonds o trans
bond che cos'è un trans bond è un
strumento finanziario che copre i rischi
che le imprese agricole le prese
d'istria lì gli stati nazionali devono
fronteggiare per mitigare e adattare le
proprie comportamenti al cambiamento
climatico
siccome c'è incertezza non si sa se
questi costi producono dei risultati
oppure no questo è il punto allora se
non si verificano gli eventi
catastrofici i miei catastrofi bond sono
come un qualsiasi debito pubblico debito
del recovery fund in europea diritti
speciali di prelievo del fondo monetario
sono una qualunque forma di debito se
però si verificano eventi catastrofici o
estremi tali per cui gli sforzi per la
mitigazione e di adattamento non hanno
un risultato il default cioè la mancanza
di ripagamento del capitale viene
sostenuto dall intervento pubblico
appunto con l'emissione di moneta
emissioni di
titoli speciali a livello internazionale
del fondo monetario
a questo punto il capitale di questi
transition bond viene dato ai settori
produttivi colpiti agricoltura industria
infrastrutture pubbliche quindi diventa
sostanzialmente un fondo perduto se c'è
la catastrofe rimane un titolo
finanziario di mercato normale se non
c'è la catastrofe e questo è un modo per
avere un futuro migliore per ridurre
l'inquinamento secondo si è comunque
meglio che fare annunci vacui che dicono
vogliamo un mondo emissioni zero
ma se la gente non investe nelle nuove
tecnologie e l'incertezza non li fa
investire non arriveremo mai ad avere
quei risultati che vogliamo
del resto stabilizzare il clima deve
voler dire stabilizzare lo sviluppo
economico la democrazia e la pace nel
mondo li dobbiamo ottenere come
argomenti collegati
del resto se pensiamo al fatto che uno
sbuffo di fumo per strada inquina questo
è tanto grave quanto a lasciare un
giovane senza istruzione è tanto grave
quanto lasciare un malato senza un letto
di ospedale che non è stato costruito
per insipienza dei governanti quindi
dare alle generazioni future un ambiente
di vita sostenibile una qualità di bene
pubblico deve essere radicata nelle
coscienze individuali e non evocata
soltanto a parole green quindi e vengo
alla conclusione vuol dire dare a
ciascuno il senso di appartenere a una
comunità dove l'incontro con il prossimo
il prossimo che ogni persona al di là
della vicinanza fisica
al di là del luogo del mondo dove è nata
o dove abita sono le parole dell'ultima
enciclica fratelli tutti di papà
francesco ad assisi dicevo l'incontro
con il prossimo è un valore positivo non
è un fastidio che intralcia l'egoismo di
ciascuno di noi